just gotta get the white rights oh sorry
the white right whoa you gotta get the
right whites the white right my watch
the white rice
[Music]
so a pair of vintage Levi jeans just
sold at a New Mexico auction for 76
Grand why do you think they were worth
so much someone died in them or
something dude wait wait I mean someone
famous died enough
uh from the 1880s uh okay there's a
really specific thing
inside of the pocket on a tiny little
label it says something that's a really
really uh important key a key thing on
the label that really shows a dark part
of American History is it is it like uh
what is it called evidence for like a
crime scene that's pretty tight but I
mean I already know what it is oh you do
dude say it just share with the class
man just guess just guess let's guess
yeah that's what I'm saying I'm just
waiting oh you should be the one to say
it it's it's something really dark about
American history that's the answer
something racist hmm
but why do you gotta use the word dark
in there oh my God go ahead Pat go ahead
I don't know what it says specifically
but I know that they're like racist
genes there's like something super
racist about them
because that's what I saw it's like
racist Gene you mean like Wranglers
yeah just a break
[Laughter]
um but yeah I don't know what it says
the the little label says made by white
labor
oh I want those jeans
made by white flavor good yeah but do
you know why that's the thing why it
would say made by white labor no why
they want you to know that a Chinese
person didn't make it oh
oh why did you laugh because that's
really funny
that's hilarious because it's because
normally it's made in China right but
they're like no it's not made it's not
even made in China it's that Chinese
people were doing that work yeah and
they were looked at as making things of
less quality oh like Tommy Hilfiger
this is the 1800s like they were just
laborers but they were like oh I don't
want no Chinese guy making my jeans my
question is who's the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that bought this for 76k I hope it's
some Chinese guy yeah it better be
[ __ ] Jack them on white man made this
[ __ ] yeah that's right
that's why we're not wearing it
stitching is terrible it's on the
[ __ ] wall where it belongs
right over the track it didn't know a
Chinese guy didn't buy these jeans oh
just a guy named Steve he auctioned him
he sold them
that's what I hope he's an owner of a
vintage uh denim company he bought it I
guess for the historical good front for
a racist am I right wow this guy loves
racist genes huh is it is yeah Zip Zip
Stevenson oh he's the one who sold them
he's the one who bought her he bought it
he bought him at the auction OH ZIP
Stevenson what color are they just blue
denim yeah they just look like a regular
blue denim jeans they got some Speckles
on it a little bit of splatter so
nothing special huh no no no just that
tag which is really really hard to find
because you'd have to go really old and
that tag would just have to be there
where it really illustrates I'm gonna
check on my Levi's yo who had these
pants your Levi's is going to be like
made by yellow people and I'm like wait
did I put that in there I wrote this
actually is it is that racist to buy
those jeans to buy no buy orientals no
if you're a historian or a guy who has a
museum full of jeans I think that's okay
yeah that's what he has yeah Museum full
of jeans dude that's his business that's
different yeah that is different but if
he loves racist stuff then that's it's
almost like uh almost obviously not the
same but remember when like American
Apparel became like a huge deal because
of the idea that it's like hey like
we're making this here in America which
is why we gotta charge 3x the price for
a basic and then it still couldn't
sustain yeah yeah well it's because like
that guy was the the head was like uh a
pervert Yeah [ __ ] slime ball yeah oh
what was the story on him he would um
you know like how they did those weird
shoots or the white backgrounds yeah I
heard he started white backgrounds yeah
they started uh making those girls not
very comfortable that's weird he would
like have people come over at his
assistants too he was Weinstein in them
and yeah and they would just be like
it's like oh we have to do a meeting
right now it'd be like late at night to
his house it's like a mansion like just
a bunch of naked other like models there
and stuff it's like why don't you put
this on
yeah especially when I come to America
dude but they are trying kind of coming
back American Apparel it's just under a
different name isn't it it's under made
by white labor yes wow white labor is a
good brand
labor I can get I can get behind that
100 yeah white labor white labor 100
white you know what I mean
made by all whites we're like okay if
the branding's cool that would sell so
well because people that enjoy knowing
that white people may something like
myself like why people slaved away or
something I will buy it and then braces
whites would also buy it because they
don't serves both markets everyone's
happy that's true you know what I mean
so think about it think about it any
llc's out there that want to partner
whitelabor.com
edu dude
they're educational resources as well
everything's still made in Vietnam
though for some reason but by whites
that's cool white to Vietnam expats in
Vietnam oh dude
that'd be fun yeah that's a really
unique business it really is yeah Ryan
already has the corner of the market
more in the market got it you got it
down I forgot what the new American
Apparel is called but it's so similar
and the font is exactly the same I think
they just don't have the guy now because
the v-necks go all the way down to your
[ __ ] belly button and [ __ ] and only
John Mayer wears them yeah of course
that's it he gets specially made
lengthened him and Borah they were the
same outfits I know and it's kind of
cool that like that's a thing that it
was a point of Pride that like literally
like now it's like made in China just
looks like a normal label but to have
something say not made in China and be
worth more is kind of funny yeah but
then it's not the problem with that is
not sustainable right that's why
everything ended up being outsourced
yeah it's sustainability yeah well
because everything comes down to money
at the end of it like yeah racism all
these things can be just gotta get the
white rights oh sorry the white right
whoa you gotta get the right whites
the white rice to make the right product
Pat can you pat can you tell us a little
bit about white rice white rice guys
yeah let me tell you guys about white
rice talk about it can you break those
down talk about I just like the idea
that Wrangler jeans are racist genes I'm
still I'm still on that to be honest
they kind of are though I think they
could easily be the ones that shift over
to the white labor you think that that
was like the marketing campaign they
were just like our Rebrand for Wranglers
is
animals not people yeah yeah we Wrangle
oh I see what you mean I got it what did
you see before no I don't know I didn't
even think about that I just thought of
the Jeeps honestly
cheaper English I thought they were
honestly you sound stupid now that I'm
saying out loud I thought they were
connected and now I'm realizing they're
not that's why I gotta that's why I
didn't get a Jeep Wrangler I didn't want
to be racist so I got a Grand Cherokee
there you go there you go there you go
you're gonna go the most racist you can
go yeah yeah the grandest chair the
grand wizard Cherokee the grand wizard
The Grand warlock Cherokee
guys murdered out black on black it just
could be with a red hood in the back
damn brother this is not what they wear
that's not what they wear the grand
wizard why are they all wizards and
dragons and [ __ ] because they're [ __ ]
white cookies because they like d and
dude
it started off as a DND card it just
went way out of hand it just got out of
hand yeah the role play kind of took a
mind of its own the LARPing got too
serious yeah man you ever been a game
master that [ __ ] always leads to you
know
I guess I guess they kind of are like
the Knights Templar but [ __ ] up right
yeah wait I don't even know what the
Knights Templar is speaking of all that
[ __ ] do you guys know the difference
between like um
Elks Lodge Masonic temple Knights of
Columbus no hell no I've always wondered
what's up with have you ever wondered
why they have so much fun for some
reason I only studied the Triads Yakuza
um
Kiwanis Club is that another one yeah
it's another one because there's a
masonic's building right over here and
uh there's a couple dude there's a
million yes I used to think that there
was a conspiracy theories back in the
day that they were like part of the
Illuminati I remember I used to watch
YouTube videos with that Requiem from a
Dream song
yeah it would show the dollar bill with
the with the pyramid yeah the All-Seeing
Eye it would say Masonic temples or the
Illuminati essentially so we would try
to sneak in but we never got in so I
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
they knew what the [ __ ] I mean you could
go to Masonic temples now they'd they'll
just rent not if you're trying to sneak
in there but what's like what's like the
uh interesting history about them well I
just don't understand why they're
[ __ ] eight floors
because we've done shows at Masonic
temples where the first two floors were
like theaters and then we went exploring
and we went to like one of the top
floors just for fun and it was like
there was one gigantic Hall that had
nothing but like unused mannequins
up yeah some eyes wide shut [ __ ] I'm
weird
you did you found the torture but you
found the white labor [ __ ] entire but
I feel like these things are made vague
for a reason because like you know like
we've seen them all our lives but nobody
can give us like a really good
explanation everything just the only way
to find out is if you infiltrate and you
join the club and you gotta pay the
Freemasons Ryan looks like you gotta
join right wild but is it just like a
like a is this like a social club like
what is this [ __ ] you're looking at me
like I'm supposed to have answers here
bro I'm just as clueless as you are but
I'm down I'm down to go join the [ __ ]
Freemasons
it's a cool name isn't it they sound
pretty [ __ ] cool and then you get
like a ring or something with a little
does it have to do with masonry
I don't know
bricks and [ __ ] man if it's a sex club
that's chill though I'm done with that
[Music]
[Music]